il ne reste plus rien de la maison
l'explosion entendue jusqu'à six
kilomètres à la ronde a tout détruit
seuls quelques objets permettent
d'imaginer où se trouvait le salon où
les cuisines à l'intérieur vivait un
couple la femme a dû être sorti des
décombres
elle est ce soir toujours hospitalisé
l'homme âgé de 76 ans conscient à
l'arrivée des secours est lui plus
gravement blessé il a été transféré à
l'hôpital de lyon en état d'urgence
absolue
les riverains sont sous le choc j'ai
entendu une très violente déflagration
et non j'ai même senti la pression d'air
et en me retournant j'ai vu une boule de
feu
moi j'habite à venir à 100 m 2 au dessus
et une boule de feu de sur une dizaine
de mètres en hauteur au dessus du foyer
du foyer qui est derrière la toiture je
suis arrivé là il ya déjà des voisins
qui étaient présents et au milieu des
gravats il y avait une personne âgée qui
était accroupi qui peinait je pense
qu'ils étaient bien à sonner pendant
toute la matinée les équipes de sapeurs
pompiers ont déblayé la zone
la famille des sinistrés a ainsi pu
récupérer quelques affaires
le linge est là par terre si on avait
décollé sur la peau quoi ac il est très
touché très touché
ils ont retrouvé du coup dans les dents
les déblaiements vous avez regardé un
peu dans les affaires beaucoup de papier
là alors il faut que ça avec mon
beau-frère pas qu'on le garde avec mon
beauf est léger vulgaire sa sacoche
bon il ya une carte d'identité il est à
la police il ya des papiers sur la
pollution
l'origine de l'explosion n'est toujours
pas précisément connues mais il ne fait
guère de doute que le gaz a joué un rôle
important
le couple venait d'ailleurs d'acheter
une bouteille de gaz pour sa maison on
est le matin de bonne heure les deux
personnes sont en pyjama dans un seau ou
au lit au lever il est possible qu'une
accumulation de da soit produite pendant
la nuit
défaut d'aération ou par suite mais ça
c'est une enquête qui tentera de
déterminer
l'explosion a eu des conséquences aussi
pour le voisinage certaines maisons ou
voiture garée à proximité ont été
endommagés deux jeunes couples dont un
avec enfants ont dû être relogés enfin
la mairie a mis en place une cellule
d'aidé psychologique
elle avait déjà accueilli plus d'une
quinzaine de personnes cet après midi le
dispositif va se poursuivre au centre
médico psychologique du creusot